hello and welcome to this video this is
round 10 coverage of the candidates
tournament yeah what happened in round
10 well I have to be honest there we had
three not so exciting games and one very
nice game so I'm going to get the three
not so exciting once out of the way and
come to the main course um yeah a little
bit more quickly than usual me let's see
and we start with kayaking gearing yeah
kayaking still in the lead of this event
with plus two and geary with nine
drawers certainly needs to win a game he
was very close to a win against koala
but he defended like a lion and it was
given I've drawn yeah okay this game we
have sloth turning into a semi sloth and
a keratin goes III yeah this is not a
boring opening at all it's um yeah
sometimes not quite fair what people
sometimes yeah tell about Giri on social
media and some that is so boring
whatever he has a very high draw right
and there were some games in this event
that were a bit strange of held they
really didn't display the proper
fighting spirit I think or willing the
willingness to take some risks to win
this event but here this is kind of
black opening is totally okay it's not
boring at all we'll see what happens
Bishop d3 Bishop e7 yeah okay I can also
goes for a very sound solid nine year
three rook c8 now before yeah this idea
has been known for quite a while the sum
blockade of the c5 square um yeah black
um should try for some counter play
against this and yeah Aguirre I think
shows how it should be done you plan to
move a five directly now you need to do
something if you as black yeah don't
play actively the danger is that this
Bishop won't be seven stays incarcerated
and will never do anything anything
anything useful in the game so a five
makes lots of sense um queen bee three
by kayaking would be one also has been
seen in this position it's all it's very
very similar and after Brooke be one
however there are some technical
possibilities that probably kayaking did
not want to allow there's been a game
for example the recent game between
Mammadyarov and navara where Navarro
here played the remarkable move c5 an
idea that is not unknown of course in
the in this opening black sometimes can
play in this brutal way and ticks ticks
here and buy tix Luke chicks yeah and
this is surprisingly and totally fine
for black he's got this ideas on the C
file and take and swing the rook over in
that mentioned game after would be 595
nice one Jay the draw is already
unavoidable it's quite quite a funny
position there's the maid threat and the
threat of the perpetual and yeah the
white has to take care of this first and
now has to allow the perpetual yeah
quite quite funny so queen bee three is
probably played because of this idea so
that that C file
action is avoided yeah give replace a 5
this is technically a novel team but not
really a very surprising movie i mean ii
five make sense get some play in the
center 94 what this traded and g6 yeah
and here the question is I mean what
white is some now playing is more or
less yeah what is forcing the game
continuation it's a there is very little
that both sides can do to avoid what
happens in the game so we can try to
look here if white can do much more
maybe this is not the case he play some
the capture of it yeah okay what other
moves are there if white plays Bishop b2
here he has to reckon with this and
after Knight takes for example then
check Bishop takes h2 comes into
consideration it's it's not easy not
easy to play this black because of that
diagonal but it doesn't seem to me oh
yeah it doesn't seem to be able to
punish him directly there was a weird
sentence white does not seem to be able
to punish this directly yeah this is at
the end played by coyoacán this those
trades and it would be all nice and good
if white would be able to prevent black
from playing civ 5 and but this happened
and now we have you see this tempo and
at the same time the support move the
support for the movie 5 yeah Quincy to
tempo
and here we go yeah and this signals
that black has completely equalized in
fact from from so if you look at this
just a bit superficially you think that
black is even better but this rook
ending is ultimately nothing Jack here
they here they agree to a draw um yeah
not much that that you can do if black
goes here which is probably the easiest
we get this ending and yeah this ending
is just a complete draw I mean it is a
draw without this pawn so not really
much to play for and black and never
promote the pawn of course so in a draw
not a very exciting game but there's no
particular reason to blame the black
player for that if you mean coyoacán
played into this opening this is one of
Gary's main defenses against e4 and if
he came up with this new idea a queen
bee three and well after if I basically
didn't have anything in store it's just
what it is like him has equalized
comfortably and he cannot play for win
just like that out of the position that
he where he has a quality and not much
more so not very exciting certainly an
okay result for kayaking yeah it'd be
better to win but the draw is not bad at
all if you lead the event um yeah Gary
has ten draws now and four rounds left
so time time to win time to win okay um
next game to check is swidler Nakamura
both players basically out of contention
for the spot to play against causal
let's see what they do okay I've got an
English opening with g3 and Bishop
reform funny thing is we now we'll look
at three three remaining games and they
all had this opening it's really
funny is one of them absolute yeah
trends in this in this tournament that
c-45 gets played a lot well then see for
itself is kind of another big surprise
see for the English opening has become a
lot more popular and recent recent month
and it may be yeah last one or two years
and because it avoids many problem
openings that dead white face is quite
regularly for the e4 players the Berlin
the marshal the disease are difficult
and even a lifelong efore players with
lab experiments with 1c form there are
also some other reasons 1c form gets
played more one is that grune felt type
of things are not so easy to get there
because let's say 9f 693 what is
basically threatening me for him and if
black want some green felt type of game
he would have to play d5 and this is
probably somewhat questionable I mean
more than it is bad but it'sit's doesn't
have a have the reputation of equalize
of equalizing comfortably black can try
some other group held each type of
things like see 593 d5 but this are all
this is all not so well explored ground
so this is I think one reason for c4
being more popular another little point
is by the way that it also avoids or ads
interesting twists two lines in the
sloth defense now c6 the slaf here from
CC from seasick CM white has additional
ideas for example and this or this this
is quite interesting to avoid the
mainstream theory and go for something
new okay but we have 55 and this is the
most popular move on almost all levels
understandably so I think c-45 is
probably the most logical reply ok so
here got d6 this is
not the main line probably rupee eight
is the main and oil for those two moose
these things of course not bad this is
maybe the most them yeah it's solid to
the right word it's a it's the simplest
move let's say rookie aid our reform
they are a lot more direct in technical
in nature 93 and age six yeah black
fields that Bishop g5 could be a problem
so h6 is the temple well spent um yeah
this is this whole position is very much
resembling in English sorry L in
Sicilian with reversed colors with
Bishop to b5 and it's not so easy to
give wide advise how to develop some
real initiative in this position one a
DM can be to play 95 at some point
trying to trade those nights and maybe
play on the C files or something like
this i'm just showing the IDM so that
after the night moves wide will be able
to play on the C file this is one idea
for what you can also try to play III
and deform this is this kind of thing
after some preparation in the game night
a force plate in an interesting try yeah
the night is just going away from the
possible capture we know that this is so
dangerous but idea is just a three
before and to rest at Bishop Nakamura
goes a five this prevents um before b3
now if white tries a three membership c5
and there is really no reason for black
to be afraid of that because here those
pawns have very good central control and
blacks play is going to be very easy he
just placed the bishop out Queen and
then centralizes everything
just a very nice centralized position
giving up the bishop pair is not such a
big deal as the central control is so
strong yeah so b3 Bishop b2 and Bishop
f5 yeah the whole set up that black
chooses here is all very natural and we
see that he develops a very very simple
fashion and maybe queen to d7 and Bishop
maybe three comes into it comes into
mind yeah right now tries to play for
that d for IDM and now Queen moves again
yeah he was probably yeah he only wanted
to clear this square for the night we
will see something very very similar in
the game um aronian to par love this is
the game we will look at after this
money 95 yeah this was one idea the
other idea as I mentioned is to play
deform and with deform however white
always has to be a little bit cautious
about this about this pawn black gets to
pin then this pawn would be hanging so
something this is something that white
can play but it's not very very
one-sided Black has discounter play
against the center yet 95 was tried in
this game and now and the next couple of
moves are pretty forced takes takes
Knight back to you seven and deform yeah
this is an idea that white employs quite
often in this structure here Black's
main concern is that he has a pawn here
on a half-open file and if he is not
careful this could be a liability but
Nakamura um yeah takes care about this
very very quickly
28 3 m.e for supporting this pawn and
now like crazy six so immediately trying
to yeah getting rid of this obstructing
pawn on d5 I think this is just the
right decision and probably leads to
equal play and we have all those
captures him and him and now before that
was probably the idea that swidler based
his play upon all these captures and
they yeah he was going for this for this
point yeah but should be six now by
nakamura he carefully calculated that
the capture on the six is not putting
him in too much danger black also could
have taken him and this kind of thing
but I don't know if you want to want to
play this position here you're like
Bishop takes Bishop takes em unsure what
black can do is you can take on Ollie
form after takes play rook age four and
this forces a draw threatening the maid
and check the draw yet in the game
nakamura played but should be six and
Sevilla took that pawn yeah rook takes
you for and yeah black now after 26 is a
porn down and a couple of pieces are
hanging but he just has this one Luke 88
yeah it's a funny it's a funny point in
the game we see what happens after Queen
takes b6 so um you know I can show it
right away sweta took this now and then
the game ended in a draw immediately
after root page for threatening mate and
after the capture which was played that
has this perpetual check check check
so we could try to find an improvement
why does a pawn up after all and this
move is a bit tougher but I understand
why Spiller didn't go for it because I
think blacks play is just very dangerous
and there's very little upside to this
move I mean black rotating and now we
can just continue this attack the thing
is that the bishop is still not hanging
due to that rook age three resource so
black can play if he likes move like
into age seven or so and ask white ok
you really don't want to take on b6 and
make it wrong here yeah and if white
tries to avoid it oops that was stupid
black and try to attack like that for
example also route 86 comes into
consideration so black is kind of
increasing the pressure piling up and
why probably should take this let's say
emergency exit by grabbing the bishop
and just make the draw this is really
all that you can expect from this
position so swing and a camera ended in
the draw the next game two chickens
Aronian to pawn off and we already know
the opening and yep the same time and
funny enough and also this one yea
though this is those two games are twin
games in a way very very similar ok five
identical b3 and now Queenie 7 this is
Sir I think different right let me have
a look yeah rook e8 was played by
nakamura Queenie 7 here by to Palo and
it's all it's it's nearly identical I
mean you can change the
move or ZM Bishop b2 Bishop c5 and
tier-iii we have you had the same thing
again they are taking on c5 it's not
leading to much at all for white III
push it back 93 okay it and now we come
to a totally new idea I mean not totally
new for chess but can do if you compare
this game 2 when the game is villa
Nakamura night to h4 by aronian um
interesting move and to be honest I
don't quite don't quite understand the
point because what I mean why does not
want to play f4 definitely not and
possible 95 90 xt5 usually is answered
by C txt five anyways so I'm not quite
sure why you have to move the night yeah
I'm slightly at a loss I mean it does
not really her Dwight definitely not but
I'm not totally sure what the point is
yet Apollo went back to the eighth the
reason is just like any other game he
wants to clear that you seven square for
this night which makes me question the
move 27 in the first place but this is
not a very temple sensitive position so
went back wide centralized see 692 and
now night f5 so this gets traded and now
deform yeah I think why term is probably
not unhappy about the recent
developments yes got some expansion
going in the center on the other hand
black is certainly also not so unhappy
he has quite decent pieces
and no particular weaknesses c3 like now
captured and now I think the next move
is probably not that great by to par
love he plays night to your form try to
trade two pairs of minor pieces I think
instead maybe Bishop 83 was better to
just trade the bishops and then play
green to d7 White has a little bit more
space but this should never be a big
problem the issue with his move is I
mean the idea is understandable i had to
trade us some pieces and because you
have less space and this is quite often
a key IDM to trade off some pieces when
you're maneuvering room is limited the
problem with this is that after all
those captures and look at you one yeah
blankets losing this battle on the
e-file and janice this happened green a
fire and here white is just better and
it's not yeah I mean it's critically am
we see rookie seven happening if a black
instead would have played twin to d7 the
bone is hanging this is the problem
you're currently slightly gasps slightly
and some some slight coordination issues
yeah quinta f5s mentioned Ruby Sam rugby
eight and Kim G to yeah this cover some
some wood squares Queenie to also was
possible instead of this move but we see
an something that is very very similar
to that d5 and now i have to admit that
again i don't quite understand the next
couple of moves by by wide here it
failed to mean that the move Queen ef3
looks very
very normal and obvious also keeping
some tension here in the center he
played c5 just to show what him but this
looks I think pretty logical we look at
this f7 pawn and the Queen cannot really
avoid the train if you go back in just
grab on d5 so trades check and now there
is still some tension and I think this
is more promising than plain c5 after
which the substructure becomes very very
rigid here um yeah sometimes maybe like
taking Andrew t7 becomes an option to
just win this pawn and wine also has the
more active King the king he is actually
doing something probably that King it to
King be three at least covering some
entry squares on the enc file I think
this is better it's just better than c5
of it ok this was played by Aronian
check yeah it is it also looks promising
but it seems that ultimately after yeah
bishops III is the next one I would
still probably play Queen a three but
after this black gets in rook c8 and now
it seems that a black is ok because
black and move this bishop next leads to
the rook trade yeah the alternative was
some move like this to being able to
keep the rukon I think this is also more
aggressive than when Aronian tried after
look at eight bishops 70 now heads to
trade and now we have a position just
with bishops and queens and this the
disadvantage that white had with this
yeah superior space and the invaded rook
only seven is now gone in fact um black
has a couple of more pawns on light
squares and
in the game went on to expand a little
bit yeah i mean if anybody black is a
little bit better here but of course the
situation is very very blocked and it it
gets even worse check here with this
with gy therefore i mean it looks pretty
awkward for white because your bishop on
f2 is just bad but the position is so
closed that this is not becoming a
factor the only thing that white has to
avoid is black yeah invading some
somewhere on the light squares but this
guy can only happen if you basically
fall asleep over the board um now that
the place apt look more moves actually
check yet year after be 658 agreed to a
draw yeah not a very exciting game i
think the system here shown or chosen by
nakamura or tupolev seems to be quite
reliable for black yeah it's a so GG
cleaver founded system that it's
difficult to attack with white even
though he aronian if he would have
avoided those um those piece trades
could have suppressed in this game yeah
it didn't ultimately lead to anything
after c5 but here he had to get a little
something probably ninety four was not
so precise but apart of okay now we come
to the main the main feature let's say
of this video the game Caruana Arnold
yeah already said that it's an English
opening so I did no big surprise we have
the same the same line yeah but now we
she plays differently he plays the
sharpest and most interesting when the
position the movie form and we yeah we
can thank him for that that really led
to an interesting game I think more
interesting then what we saw in the
earlier games we're live on and down and
swimmer had the white pieces okay 95
takes takes rook e8 f3 we have seen this
before in the games villa kayaking we're
kayaking now went for the very
enterprising idea III um very sharp
stuff after d3d 5s will they went
between a form and it was a very sharp
interesting game another ever captures
and this is something that he has played
before numerous times actually it's not
just in one game so it was something
that could be expected him Knight takes
and d5 yeah very interesting again is
strategically black gives up the bishop
app but still goes for an opening of the
position this is as we had in some some
other in games already in the tournament
due to his development and due to some
concrete ideas if white captures on d5
Queen takes d5 is played and there are a
couple of interesting ideas black hand
for example go for this and potentially
bishop age 30 jobs oh would ya be the
end of the payoff bishops yeah he blacks
I think lively piece play is a very good
compensation for the bishop pair note
that the pawns also cannot be used that
quickly and easily if white tries this
move then yeah black can just yeah
continue with normal more not sorry
normal moves let's say this in
particular will be an issue for wild d
forever his plate by Caruana and yeah
this move was introduced into tournament
practice by Kasparov here almost 30
years ago
it's a long time I so remember seeing
that game in a chance magazine and being
surprised how wide can win so quickly
with the English opening um yeah it is
an interesting interesting try and much
more aggressive than 65 yeah takes I
wonder I'm put it what did you want to
play I think he oneshot played this move
I should have looked that up actually I
didn't I think I think he played this
one Quincy to and why I know that white
I remember that why plate son luca p1
and also after some f5 there was g4 it
was a very dynamic game by Kasparov um
okay but Alan plays differently he plays
the capture on c4 yeah here White has a
couple of choices the most popular move
is probably the move Bishop to g5
directly pinning the night and
potentially with the half-open FR tried
to inflict double points ahead of the
kingside for black and this mover ever
seems to be okay for black there has
been they've been again Aronian honored
for example last year where we she held
quite comfortably light if I've now for
example isn't leading to much this for
example and yeah white has no clear way
forward from here yeah I mean something
like this is certainly okay for white
but also black cannot complain he's a
pawn up has active pieces nothing
terrible going on karana comes up with a
really singles it's not a novelty but
it's a it's not very common twin to see
two um yeah I don't know place age six
I think in the you of the Bishop g5 idea
a pretty pretty reasonable choice Bishop
f4 just centralizing and now nitey force
plate only this is the it's the novelty
technically there is a game in the
database between to an overrated players
when night e seven was played which
really fields after yeah after you for
offs and 95 feel some a little bit
passive and this was probably even
stronger preventing night g6 in the
first place so Allen's move certainly
certainly better there also was 95 but
after the eform I think him and wide
we'll probably be happy with this broad
sent to him he definitely has
compensation for his his pawn but 94
happened yeah a couple of choices white
already can play Knight e5 but this move
was some clarifying the tension quite
quite early and hoops I'm sorry and rook
t1 now this was the move by Kerwin I
think this is the more interesting move
introducing the idea of playing possibly
d5 the right moment and asking the Black
Knight where it wants to go it's also
rook against screen on the same file
which is really really often useful okay
Bishop to f5 note that kawana clearly
was still in his preparation we're
honored had to had to think yeah 95
looks very logical attacking taking this
um yeah what about night takes g3 Allah
didn't play that and if he would have
gone for that bite of course goes efore
very
funny sequence now root gets taken takes
him and yeah black probably should try
to get a pawn at least four is very
snide takes h2 and Bishop h2 a very
strange material distribution blackest
quadric and three pawns for two bishops
the two bishops are ever are placed very
actively very aggressively and I think
that why it should be ok here i watched
part of yen Gustafsson's video on the on
this game only watched the beginning and
basically the opening up up to this
point roughly and then I had to leave
unfortunately alien um it was not I
didn't stop the video because it was so
bad or anything just in case you think
it was a very good in fact up to this
point um well um Yun discussed that he
thinks that white is better here
possible I mean I know that he is
probably an almost yeah equally awful
Bishop fetishist so yeah we probably
have similar tastes as him I also think
that white can be happy and then bishops
are very strong and it's not clear what
blacks plan is something like this and
well I think here White's plans like
this and everything is also hanging yeah
you can stop for black tube to cover all
the points i think what is probably
happy here especially in a game between
human players yeah are not avoided this
and just went back to d6 um before yeah
White has won this battle here in the
center Bishop back and Queen to you too
the queen is looking at this but also
looking get what's three over
to the King side and try to make black
skin feel insecure and 97 now by Alan
and in the view of the upcoming
complication you could try to improve on
that move I don't think it's
particularly bad it's just that the
positions after it gets extremely
difficult to handle so 97 and here in
this position it's possible that koalas
move which he played after about 30
minutes I think if I'm if I remember
correctly I watched part of the
broadcast um it's possible that this is
even not the best move from a purely
it's a mathematical engine type of
tablet perspective but this is only half
of the truth it's just it's very very
tough to defend after it he took on h6
going for the spear sacrifice it was not
necessary to do that I mean why it would
have been better also with let's say
yeah normal strategic moves rookie one
Bishop Bishop back here to reroute a
tech f7 a couple of things that he could
have done so it's not a necessary
sacrifice in a way and we should note by
the way that this simple move is not so
great due to 95 this is actually quite
annoying looking at those two ND for of
courses attacked yeah but let's look at
this he sacrificed the bishop Wow okay
Alan decided ultimately to take it
interesting that he took quite a long
time you would think that there was
really no alternative if you don't take
it you're like you're lost anyway but ok
he decided to to check and now Queen to
h5 that was the point and it's really
remarkable white has given this form
just one porn at the moment but f7 is a
tech and h6 of the text
it's really quite clearly impossible to
defend both by some yeah by some simple
move let's aim yeah if for example like
king here yeah that's just night at
seven and black is exploding or look at
eight covering this then why this going
to take on h6 and this is also not going
to end well yeah white has very simple
attacking ideas like this is this or
will gave six yeah if black takes for
example here both ideas actually that's
very unadvisable the thing is they're
probably is a way to defend the position
but this is something that is simply
beyond human capabilities i think the
the move that seems to save black is 92
d5 it's I mean okay the point is that
now the queen is opened up here and this
comes into play after he takes d5 and
queen g5 why it is better after we near
3m this however is not the only line
that black if we think about this from
blacks perspective head to spot which is
this is not easy in the first place but
the most threatening looking move is
neither 70 in this position and him the
amazing thing is that the move Knight f6
which is a bit of a shocker seems to
hold it's pretty amazing and then the
Queen Hanks but if white takes it then
half the night takes h5 this didn't make
any sense yeah this is a trap piece so
what should why do we can check here
okay black goes into the corner and
after the Queen goes back
black only has one move again he has to
do this rook takes Bishop takes Knight
eggs and amazingly the engine gives us
as a totally equal position he'd find
some wacky perpetual a couple of couple
of moves later um but who on earth is
going to find that like this Wow yeah
very very remarkable lying yeah I can
tell you who didn't find it a lot but as
I said it's it's very very yeah it's
it's almost inhuman to see that he
played this move right ETF five
returning a piece that covers both but
of course it's not idea here right now
can happily trade on g5 okay and play
the moon f6 and this is awkward now we
dealing with an equal material position
now where white has the much better
pieces than the bishop on g2 is strong
the knight on d5 is is excellent and
that pawn on f6 is limiting blacks yeah
scope of activity quite a bit so if
black now starts to defend yeah
perfectly with stuff like c6 or look a
2d eight he still could have yeah hold
on held on the form could have held on
yeah I think that's right um quite quite
tenacious Lee I don't ever place night
to your form it tries to be more active
but yeah this seems to lead into even
more trouble koalas move now is look fe1
and it is not bad at all however the
simple captures pointed out by the
computer and then h4 and this is
probably even stronger the biggest point
is that black cannot take on h4
because Luke f1 is winning then for
example this check check and now
checkmate checkmate yeah a couple of
mates and all this check check it is not
made but doesn't change the result it's
really very funny black cannot take on
each form so he has to play whatever and
then what can you even think of just
think about just taking one g five so
that solution was probably even stronger
I think what Kara wanna calculate mostly
is what he played he played rookie one
and he saw that night xe3 is not working
and if that's not working black is just
basically obliged to go back to these
things taking that pawn doesn't really
help as Bishop d7 will crash through on
them on the diagonal my protested this
yeah Anna took it on c3 and this is
ultimately losing after nineteen sixty
was worse but could continue this is the
problem now you cannot grab on a to as
after Luke see for all the escape
squares of the night I controlled so the
night will get lost and yeah this is
what what is still try it and put now
here we should be seven and it's
impossible now for black to hold yeah
here's awkward double attack we tried 94
and here why this is an exchange up
check always check Nate look for
checkmates Chang you have to look at one
now honored resigned he's forced now to
trade books check and after this rook
gets traded the issue is that many black
pawns look over the ocean are still weak
and will likely fall victim to the rook
so we went by car wanna very nice win
with this great Bishop takes h6 move
also very good preparation I think this
was largely also the fruit of good home
prep this idea was difficult for for
wishing to handle and it seems that he
did not have the super deep preparation
they're available um yeah very nicely
played by a koala who with this win also
gets two plus two so he joins them
kayaking in the lead and honored after
this loss is back to a plus one squad
not out of it but this is this kind of
loss against direct contender like
Ramona is a problem because now for
example analysts have a point behind
kawana but if he catches him that
doesn't help because kawana has won this
game and is the leading in their
head-to-head matchup so uneven scores um
karana would advance makes it difficult
for Vichy especially that he is also
behind one point against kayaking ok
against kayaking he's playing on this on
this Thursday in round 11 so with a
windy could actually even the individual
med school but okay still 4 rounds to
play I hope you enjoyed the coverage the
tournament is getting more exciting I
think every round and we will certainly
have yeah lots of tension
the final round and around before that
will be very very close call I guess
okay thanks for watching